So now that we know the different types of neurons, sensory, motor and
interneurons, and how electrical impulses result in action potentials. Let's
see what happens after the action potential occurs. Remember once again that
the signal starts from the dendrites and moves down the axon to the terminal
buttons. In Lauren's depiction here at the Terminal button, we have synaptic
vesicles that are holding neurotransmitters. Neurotransmitters are then
released into the synaptic cleft. And if those neurotransmitters attach to the
receptors on the opposite neuron, the message will continue along. Think of
receptors as a lock and the neurotransmitters as a key. If the neurotransmitter
attaches to the receptor site, the message will continue along, through the
next neuron.